[Music]
but while i may be the first woman in
this office
i will not be the last if kamala harris
becomes
vice president i mean a lot to locals
just like me
i can't believe someone that looks like
me made it to the white house
representation in our government is so
important
[Music]
so mindy kelling shared a post crying
and holding my daughter
look baby she looks like us and it
literally sums up
everything it turns up the fact that so
many
young girls are going to be able to see
themselves in that position too
from a young age karma harris being
elected as vp today would mean that we
black brown female communities are being
represented it gives us a seat at the
table
it gives us a voice a voice that will be
heard for the disenfranchised it also
represents an historical first
my grandparents actually grew up in the
jim crow south they grew up in a town
called brunswick georgia and brunswick
georgia was a very
very segregated town at the time there
were the colored fountains that were so
much lower in quality than the white
fountains my grandparents were
not allowed to eat at certain
restaurants not allowed to ride in the
front of the buses
black people were not allowed to assume
powerful positions in society
my grandparents lived of extremely
unfair existence and there was nobody
who could truly speak
to the experiences that they faced
that's why it's just so
amazing to see hamlet harris elected
into office a woman from an hbcu
howard university my grandmother's alma
mater having a seat at that table a seat
formerly held by old white men
the more diverse viewpoints we have we
can speak to more and more
pockets of american society and enact
laws
that will really help the whole it's
just incredibly reaffirming i
think it's like very inspiring to see a
south asian woman
being in this position i don't see a lot
of women
and especially women of color and
important roles
i would love to see that change so
little girls like
me can see themselves in places where
decisions are made
it mean there was hope for me to become
president one day it would also make me
very happy
because my dad's black and my mom's an
indian
just like her parents it would also help
other people realize that black lives
matter
black people are just as plain as
everybody else
being on a visa i cannot vote but
senator harris thing in the office is
the least i can expect
of my experience and voice being heard
and represented in this country which i
hope to call home in the future
she gives me hope for the future and
makes me want to dream big
and now it also helps to cement
the historical context that rbg left for
us
women women who work women who want to
be represented women in government
it's also heartwarming that after
a regime that has been so egregiously
villainous racist misogynistic
xenophobic transphobic homophobic
intoxic
to see that this is the american
response to elect
a woman so marginalized in society who
shares
the experiences of the people who have
some of the smallest voices
it just means so much that that is the
american response
to hatred this is an historical moment
and we should all
be cheering
[Music]
you